une foule en liais sans Caras pour fêter
5 années de plus et celui qu'il qualifie
de père de la nation après 20 ans
Erdogan reste le maître de la Turquie je
tiens à remercier chacun des membres de
notre nation qui une fois de plus nous
ont confié la responsabilité de
gouverner le pays pour les 5 prochaines
années une gigantesque coulait debout
qui dévale et emporte tout sur son
passage
elle passe même au-dessus de ce mur
la route les rues de ce petit village de
Champé se transforme en rivière frame
sur le célèbre lac Majeur en Italie
quatre personnes ont péri dans le
chaviron d'un bateau hier soir une
vingtaine d'autres touristes ont été
secourus certains sont parvenus à
rejoindre le rivage juste après le
naufrage l'accident pourrait avoir été
provoqué par un tourbillon en trois
quarts d'heure seulement d'après le
maire il est tombé pas moins de 66
litres d'eau au mètre carré un torrent
si fort si violent que cette route n'a
pas résisté le professeur Raoult a-t-il
réalisé le plus grand essai
thérapeutique sauvage c'est ce que
dénonce une quinzaine de sociétés
savantes dans une tribune parue hier sur
le site du monde il reproche alliasu de
Marseille la prescription systématique
de l'hydroclaroquine à plus de 20000
patients atteints de covid un grand
sommet autour du plastique est organisé
toute cette semaine à Paris
175 pays sont représentés le professeur
Raoult fustige cite une tribune
d'imbéciles que les autorités de santé
viennent faire leur enquête sur
l'hydroxychloroquine pollution plastique
c'est donc une bombe à retardement en
même temps qu'un fléau qui est déjà
présent c'est notre devoir d'y mettre
fin le plus vite possible l'objectif
c'est de préparer un traité
international qui devrait mettre fin à
l'utilisation des plastiques à usage
unique d'ici à 2040 l'appareil made in
China atterrit sur le tarmac avec 7 ans
de retard sur le calendrier initial
cela n'empêche il est fêté en grande
pompe par les patriotes chinois le Grand
Canal de Venise qui vire au vert fluo
l'étrange nappe de couleur est apparu
hier matin alors que la ville
accueillait une course d'aviron objectif
pour l'entreprise d'État Comac rattraper
la concurrence occidentale et répondre
elle-même à sa forte demande de vol
domestique ce changement de couleur ne
serait pas dangereux pour l'homme ni
polluant il s'agirait d'un colorant
déversé intentionnellement côté
technologique là encore le C919 est en
retard par rapport à ses concurrents
selon certains experts il correspond à
un bon appareil mais produit dans les
années 80 les Vénitiens pensent à une
action coup de poing de militants
écologistes ce flyer sera distribué à
partir de demain et tout au long de
l'été par les policiers et gendarmes 5
millions de tracts pour lancer une
campagne de prévention sur la sécurité
des femmes dans l'espace public la
dernière hypothèse pourrait être celle
d'une performance artistique déversée un
colorant vert fluo dans le Grand Canal
c'est ce qui avait fait un artiste
argentin en 19 68 pour sensibiliser à
l’écologie composée d'un QR code le
flyer redirige vers le site du ministère
de l'Intérieur ma sécurité.fr il permet
de signaler des faits et discuter avec
les forces de l'ordre 24 heures sur 24
la réalisatrice française Justine Trier
a remporté la Palme d'or pour anatomie
d'une chute problème sous le coup de
l'émotion elle en oublie son diplôme
l'actrice américaine Jane Fonda tente de
la rattraper avant de perdre patience et
de lui jeter tout simplement le
parchemin dans le dos est-ce que ça
avait vraiment sa place dans une
cérémonie internationale mais elle a
parfaitement raison les artistes ne
vivent pas dans un monde à part ils ne
vivent pas dans un igloo et ils ont
encore le droit de dire un certain
nombre de choses sur la société sur la
réforme des retraites et donc je dis
bravo à Justine Trief elle a parlé de
néolibéralisme pour parler de la France
on est un pays qui a augmenté là encore
cette année de 7% le budget de la
culture qui a fait le choix collectif et
c'est notre honneur c'est notre fierté
de protéger la culture les artistes en
covid il y a pas beaucoup d'autres pays
qui ont fait ça mais rassurez-vous la
récompense a bien fini entre deux bonnes
mains on a le droit de s'exprimer elle
peut évidemment utiliser le tribunal le
Festival de Cannes comme une tribune
mais pas pour dire n'importe quoi